you know you were talking to me before
the show that you have a band i'm not
really familiar with your band well
you're not familiar with anything
apparently no these guys are a big part
of my life no um
i had no idea
i have no idea but i'm here to learn i'm
like the audience i'm playing the new
spider-man you've seen that that was and
i won an academy award i don't know if
you know that i didn't know you see his
oscar last night yeah
no
um
yeah well i i have a side career i guess
as a musician a serious musician yeah i
i mean i'm a serious guy
about what i do
so it whether it's comedy or music or
but it's a music
dance you're serious dancer i would love
to be a serious dancer
but yeah the music is i love i mean
music is kind of the first love of my
life really so when you came out here or
you guys started in college right you
and yeah started together in college but
it was that the dream was that the hope
to be a musician i think in maybe in
high school it would have been but in
college i got into film and started
working more
uh trying to make stuff in i loved it
all i loved theater and you had a band
in college i had a yeah had bands in
high school and college it was all it
was all going so it was like whatever
hit first you just ran with that you
know so would you ever consider you know
it would be a good thing why wouldn't
you come on america's got talent with
your band seriously
i don't wow i think it's all right i
think it's all right it's not i'm just
kidding
i mean what the kind of music i play is
definitely not popular music oh that's
good so you've got your own niche
unpopular music unpopular
it's it's what how would you describe to
talk about my music it's kind of seventy
singer songwriter
uh
sardonic i mean randy newman
who has never been popular never ran a
couple of hits but it's not current
trendy billy eilish stuff it's uh you
know it's throwback rock and roll
but it's more of like what everything
tim's done where he's like he's making
himself happy he's making himself laugh
he's making him you know he's doing the
art for himself i think and that's isn't
that what most great artists that are
successful do we had a fan uh this this
ties it together a little bit we had a
fan of office hours
uh cover one of my songs who was on uh
your show uh sarah potenza
on agt yeah she covered your song not on
she didn't cover my song on but she she
kind of blew up on uh tiktok covering
one of my songs can we can we pull that
out yeah sarah potenza she was on
america's got talent uh but not singing
your song not singing my song uh
what's the song
she covered trump uh
i did these trump oh yeah
trump tower yeah look up sarah potenza
trump tower it's happening as we speak
okay good thing we have that screen so
we can see
yeah show it here now because i really
i hope it
i'm i really like the screen now oh they
will but you know without the headsets
you're not going to hear it i know you
can imagine it on instagram or yeah
sarah potenza we got it instagram photos
and then uh i mean how do you remember
all these people i know she she she went
fairly i don't know how deep she's
playing here i think next week too i'm
gonna go see she's like
oh she is yeah i think so she's got an
incredible where's she from i should
have won where is she from
nashville but i think originally in new
york
um i think i don't know you guys can
find it she probably
she put it out officially too even if it
takes long thank god you brought an
editor
there we go because we can because
oh yeah okay let's hear so this is a
song i wrote
[Music]
since 2010
he's been
jokes
and special guests in my darker dreams
and i guess i thought when
that's a big voice
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
do you sing
yeah so you would you would sing that
when you do this i wouldn't do it like
that i mean i don't she's polishing the
turd like vic and i do yeah
[Music]
you